Dave McMenamin who has been following
the Cavs for quite some time for the
worldwide leader in sports in the NBA as
a whole insider and reporter for ESPN
back here on the show how you doing Dave
I'm great rich how are you I'm doing
fine I guess before we get to the the
Eastern Conference what were your
thoughts watching that Western
Conference Finals game last night Steve
Kerr was flat-out asked by a member of
the media if if curry was hurt and how
much his injury is affecting his play
and Kerr put his tongue in cheek and
gave a percentage from the draft lottery
what do you think I'm not so sure I was
want to call him hurt didn't he look
pretty good against the pelicans so I
mean did something happen to practice in
the time in between this is the time
where NBA players have to manage their
bodies over the course of regular season
to perform at their best in the playoffs
and I understand that he had again an
injury not aware and tare injury but if
he's on the court that's you know the
old maximum if you're playing you're not
injured and you know was he injury
causing him to start the game over six
from three to me you know the Rockets
just took it to the Warriors I got to
give credit to Mike D'Antoni for not
doing any drastic lineup changes or not
really going away from what they worked
he figured that air Gordon's do PJ
Tucker's do Trevor Ariza do and James
Harden is gonna be the same brilliant
guy he always is and and they look like
a very formidable team that's going to
give the Warriors trouble through the
rest of the story the way they played
last night all right and then as for the
Eastern Conference Finals what what's
what's tyloo to do I mean he went to
Tristan Thompson we did see a lot of the
players that they got in the Lakers
trade Rodney hood as well it seems like
he might be out of bullets here Dave
what do you think going in again yeah it
looks a little bleak other than the fact
that you had to remember that the
Celtics are still so young and they're
one in four on the road in these
playoffs
the Cavs play well to Q they have a real
home court advantage and LeBron was
getting anything he wanted until he got
you know unfortunately his children in
the faith by Jason Tatum unintentional
of course but that affected his play in
Game two
you know tyloo claims he's gonna stick
with Rodney hood he went away from
Jordan Clarkson in Game two you know
again there aren't many bullets there he
has to play these guys that he trusts
and know that can contribute on both
ends so that means Jerry Smith even
though he's going over seven you're not
gonna pull him for a guy like Jordan
Clarkson because Jerry Smith knows
defensive scheme he can get hot and you
know Todd's kind of stuck with the hand
he has here to play and he has to think
about eight Jerris seventy-seven percent
against the Raptors in the Eastern
Conference semifinals that's bound to
come back around for him I do think
you'll see more Justin Thompson because
the the word that ty used after game two
was the subjects were gooning up the
game and Tristan Thompson is the most
physical player for the Cavs so I hear
to see more Tristan Thompson and
potentially even some more Larry Nance
and then ty doesn't like to play a three
Center rotation I would be obviously
Kevin Love and Tristan and Larry Nance
Jr but I think that's going to be his
best course of action in terms of
getting guys who play with automatic
physicality out there on the court what
do you mean by gooning up the game it
wasn't a junior Smith who shoved down
Horford in the back towards the end of
the game that was already he decided
yeah the interesting choice of verbiage
by Tyler of course his player is the one
that was called out by Marcus smart for
being dirty and rightfully so that was a
play that has no business on the
basketball court it's dangerous I was a
little surprised considering JR Smith
previous history with these type of
things that he wasn't suspended for Game
three
I guess Joe Borgia the head of NBA
officials said that Albert wasn't hurt
so do you need to hurt a guy to get a
suspension now I I'm not so sure but I
think ty I'm not I'm not really sure
that he meant in a dirty connotation
other than the fact that they are
setting the tone for physicality and
what is allowed and what will be called
and what won't be called out there on
the court he wants his team to do that
same thing and and bring that to the
callee from the start and that's why
you're gonna see him sticking with
Tristan Thompson sticking with Kyle har
Smith Jerrod Smith even though he had
his problems in Game two while shooting
the ball and embarrassing the game he is
there
doesn't Goldwing defender yeah I mean
that is an interesting point Dave
McManaman of ESPN joining us here is
that you know if they're four footed
broken his arm is I mean Junior Smith
would have been suspended for as long as
Horford would have been out I mean isn't
that the flipside of that whole argument
yeah and the TNC broadcast through last
night we was talking about a play where
Ariza was bringing up the court and
draymond Green to arm shoved into him
and I said you know what if that was
Chris Paul so bring them all the court
and he actually takes the same shove but
because he's a smaller player he goes
flying into the crowd is it a different
call you know these things are tough to
call and I don't think the standard
should be injury though or the standard
should be how far a player is thrown I
think if you're an airborne player who's
defenseless that should be a pretty easy
call now I'm not so sure I would have
been in favor especially I think he
should have been thrown out of Game two
and but when you get it wrong initially
then you have to kind of make up for it
and I am a little surprised he wasn't
supposed to send him in here on the rich
I wasn't sure I don't want to stir
things up but this may sound like it
that's a heck of a caveat to the
question I'm about to ask when you say
that LeBron was affected by getting the
shoulder and in the face if this was the
NFL we would be talking about
concussions and we would be talking
about what was he doing in the game did
they put him back in the game because it
was a playoff game I mean seriously
there would be so much up in arms and I
understand the NFL is a lot more
physical game even with the NBA being as
physical as it is but if he was affected
by it
what was he concussed best we could tell
Dave I mean I can't answer that other
than to say that you know LeBron told us
that he was went through a litany a test
when he went back to the locker room
I imagine concussion protocol was one of
them but even if this was the NFL I mean
didn't the same thing happened with Tom
Brady where you know after the fact
Gisele Bundchen says that he played
through concussions and it was all
hush-hush like I mean that rule is in
place and I think it's an important one
to protect players in the long term so
there aren't things like chronic CTE
that's being perpetuated while they're
playing the game but at the same time if
you're gonna tell me that that was the
first time a player
potentially was concussed and forces way
back into the game
I don't think that'd be accurate either
remember I think Kobe Bryant in an
all-star game got hit across the face
from Dwayne Wade and returned to the
game and there was you know I thought
maybe he got concussed from that that's
an all-star game let alone an NBA
playoff game with a lot of art I was
just something that I was thinking about
watching that game certainly since he
wasn't the same player after gotten hit
hit hit across the head like that but
clearly his marbles are all there I'm
wondering with somebody who has been
covering LeBron for as long as you have
what you thought of his photographic
memory recounting of the top of the
fourth quarter in response to a question
a couple of days ago
I enjoyed it and it's something that
I've been privy to and something quite
frankly where I had to kind of get my
teeth and cues in order when I do
attempt to ask the question of him
postgame because if you get something
wrong it's not even necessarily that
he's trying to show you up but he's
gonna correct you that's the way his
brain works so you know the one thing
where I've seen it manifest itself where
you can talk you can talk to him about a
sequence and he can tell you and explain
to you how he manipulates the defense he
can say well on this possession I did a
pocket pass to our Center and that
caused their backline defender to come
up from the wing so then I knew if the
next position if I faked that pocket
pass the backline defender would come up
to meet the center and I could swing it
to the corner to an open shooter like
that's the type of special recognition
and play-by-play memory that he has that
allows him to affect the game not just
show off in a press conference and
somehow ridiculously get an applause I
still don't know everywhere I was in the
front row so I don't know who applauded
who didn't know what I don't know I need
to find that out but I just don't know
as impressive it was we shouldn't have
media members applauding we thought it
might have been like members of the Cavs
off front-office or no yeah no I don't
there's not usually and usually they're
like kind of to the corner of the page I
see those guys so I'm still not sure
well you would know so last one for you
Dave I guess and you know obviously
we're gonna chat throughout the playoffs
here the end game scenario for the Cavs
if this is it because it sure feels like
this is it that it's going to be a very
tall order for them to win the four of
the next five based on what we saw
from the first to that the way this ends
and the way that the excel takes look if
it is a total blowout does that affect
any way shape or form what happens July
1 with LeBron James or or that's gonna
go
however this ends finals Eastern
Conference Finals going seven games what
do you mean I think a lot happen in on
Tuesday night not only them losing in
blowout fashion but the fact that the
Cavs picked that they got some Kyrie
trade and only ended up being number
eight and so that is one less major
asset that they have going into the
summer so they can say to LeBron why we
got the number one pick so you want to
stick around to play with you know
DeAndre Aiden or we're gonna trade the
number one pick for Kawhi Leonard don't
you want to stay the number eight pick
doesn't have that same type of market
value so that said though the Cavs win
Game three on the home court and we're
not talking about four out of five
anymore we're talking about just a
series and so I don't think many people
in the Cavs organization are starting to
think that it's over yet you know they
go down three oh it's a different
conversation but but they look at like
they got a win on their home court and
they get to delay that conversation of
where LeBron is eventually potentially
going to go as long as they keep winning
basketball games Dave will chat down the
line thanks for the call here and and
enjoy the rest of the Eastern Conference
Finals we'll chat in the NBA Finals
you bet that's Dave McMenamin at MC ten
on Twitter here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience